some people they're just born walk very
be okay and that twist of fate makes
them better Barry did you time travel
again oh yeah alright I was studying
there I am Barry something is wrong with
reality everyone thinks for each other
we shape the world as you see fit you
did this to us
you can undo it why would I want to is
coming
I need to start acting like each other
and then we'll find the Gotham City the
rain on your parade your team betrayed
you you needed them and they weren't
there he's rewriting reality again
enough you will not do to this earth
what you did to mine
for you God
good evening Oro west-allen Gideon
another data entry
[Music]
and tree uploaded and recorded shall I
send it to the same recipient yes
entry sent would you like assistance
with anything else yes send a personal
message for me what would you like us to
say actually I'll deliver it myself
[Music]
we need to talk
yes Norah
[Music]
yes we do
everybody it's Charlie we got a whole
bunch of new DC footage to break down
new flash new Elseworlds crossover and
obviously that reverse flash scene from
last night I'll talk about the new
Elseworlds footage first then I'll talk
about reverse flash stuff of course we
have to do a new round of that blast
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from the trailer on the
video the big deal here is that they
just introduced a little bit more of the
plot and it's in a more linear fashion
the way they present some of this
footage but it's interesting that the
John degan character seems like he gets
the book twice like the monitor gives it
to him in the street outside here he
changes reality the first time because
there's a weird transition where you see
what looks like Barry running with
SuperSpeed into frame and then out of
frame in the green arrow costume that
just might be a misleading way for them
to cut the trailer but later you see
them on a rooftop where you see Barry in
the green arrow costume looking down and
then you see Oliver running you know
with the SuperSpeed in the flash costume
run up to talk to him it's not really
clear what grant gustin's first seen in
the crossover is if it's gonna be him in
this Argus facility training with Diggle
like waking up mid fight like wait a
minute what's going on here as he gives
him the Green Arrow costume so I'm just
gonna go ahead and assume that they cut
this trailer in a really misleading way
but flash is the first night of the
crossover even so they go to supergirls
earth during the flash crossover they go
to the Kent farm you meet Superman but
obviously the black suit Superman's
stuff happens a little bit later because
you're meeting the regular version of
Earth 38 Superman the first time you see
him the way they explained Lois Lane in
this universe is that everybody has
known her on supergirls earth for a long
time but obviously this is the first
time that this actress has portrayed
this character obviously it's a lot of
fun with them being on the Kent farm
from the Smallville TV series Stephen
Amell teased that there was going to be
some Smallville type Easter Egg that
would make your head spin so I don't
know what they're gonna do at this
Smallville Kent farm but apparently just
keep your eyes peeled for a really big
holy crap Smallville Easter Egg there's
a little more footage of Oliver inside
STAR Labs some slightly different
footage of him running into iris West in
the morning like wait a minute just
trying to figure everything out then
accidentally using his powers without
realizing that he now has everything
that Barry had same thing for Grant
Gustin
he has all of Oliver's abilities and all
of his scars too so that's the
interesting thing is that like their
minds somehow have not been changed
something about this will have to
explain why it is that they remember
their previous lives so maybe like at
the beginning of the trailer you see him
talking to a bunch of students in a
lecture hall
maybe he starts out being a professor or
a regular doctor of some kind then he
gets the book of Destiny from the
monitor changes everything
you get all the Oliver Barry changes the
first time in this new reality he then
has this underground lab here but it's
unclear why the monitor would bring him
the book again and you also see him like
pawing at the wall here like he's
keeping the book walled up so that
nobody else can find it or so maybe the
he won't be tempted to use it so maybe
he change his reality once and then
doesn't use it ever again and the
monitor gets upset about that so he
comes to confront him with it again like
I offered you the opportunity to be a
god show them what it means to be a god
and that's how you get two black suits
Superman because that seems like it
comes a little bit later in the
crossover we get the scene from John
Wesley Shipp talking to them inside the
lab a crisis is coming once they figure
out they need to go to Gotham that's
when they run into the Batwoman
character when they go looking for
Batman they find the bat-signal there's
actually a deleted scene Stephen Amell
said that they shot a scene where Oliver
says it's a stupid signal so he's making
fun of the bat-signal and they said they
had to cut it out it was implied that
because Warner Brothers wasn't happy
with them making fun of Batman that way
so maybe that deleted scene will make it
onto the DVDs when they released that
next year you see Barry and Oliver
talking to each other examining some of
the weirdness and the changes in their
lives like you see them looking at the
wedding picture and instead of Barry and
iris it's Oliver and iris they show up
at Arkham just as there's a prison break
going down and that's how they run into
bat woman you see her use her grappler
for the first time yanking that criminal
into the car that's what some of her
stunts will probably look like when the
bat woman TV show eventually premieres
there's a scene with her in one of Wayne
Tech's buildings the way they're
explaining her character is that they're
trying to be as true to the comics as
possible so she is Bruce Wayne's cousin
through Bruce Wayne's mother Bruce
Wayne's mother Martha Kent's birth name
is Martha Kane and obviously Kate Kane
is bat woman so that's how Bruce Wayne
and Batman are related and it also kind
of explains how she's also super rich
like Bruce Wayne not near
as rich but she's still very well-off
because her family owns a lot of real
estate so that kind of gives you an idea
for where a lot of her toys will come
from because in this universe they've
explained that Batman has been missing
for the last three years
they'll probably explain it during one
of the episodes so we'll find out pretty
soon there's actually a pretty cool
scene of killer frost with Argus it's
unclear if she's working with Argus or
if she just suiting up for a mission
during the crossover and she normally
works with team flash then you see black
suits Superman in STAR Labs this is
obviously a little bit later in the
crossover you see reverse flash so he's
obviously part of the crossover to
fighting with the Oliver version of the
flash and you see what seems like Amazo
rising up so if everybody's wondering
about this robot I'm assuming that it's
Amazo because they've already done
metallo from last season and they've
already done Red Tornado but it's
unclear if it was created by Professor
Ivo or if it was created by a different
character because I don't see any
professor Ivo and any of this footage
anywhere in this crossover so just stay
tuned for that remember the first night
of the crossover is Sunday night it'll
be the flash episode Monday night will
be part two that'll be the arrow episode
Tuesday will be part three that'll be
the Supergirl episode it'll be the
normal time that all those episodes are
on obviously my part one video will post
Sunday night I'll just remind people as
I'm posting videos across the weekend
the reverse-flash footage from last
night though there were a lot of
questions the producers did an interview
clarifying what's going on in this
moment so biggest thing first they said
that this version of the reverse-flash
is the same version that we saw during
last year's crossover when he said to
Barry I wonder what face I'll be wearing
next time we meet turns out the next
time that we the audience meet him he's
still wearing that same face they didn't
say exactly when it happened but they
said sometime after this moment where he
runs off and Barry lets him go he gets
caught in the future thrown in iron
Heights and that's when Nora comes to
him they just say that somebody caught
him in 2049 and he's been in prison ever
since then so Nora came back to find him
knowing that he was really smart and
could probably help her save her father
from crisis on Infinite Earths in 2024
but here's the really cool thing you
guys will be really hyped up about in
the second half of the season they said
that in episode 10 they would completely
answer what they're doing together in
plan would be revealed it across the
back half of the season you get more
scenes with them silence of the lamp
style Clarice talking to Hannibal Lecter
behind the glass so if it wasn't clear
reverse-flash is now back on the TV show
and he'll be in many episodes in the
back half of the season I'm still hoping
that he winds up being the secret big
bad of the season but we'll get more
clues about that as we see their
relationship develop in the coming
episodes but that won't come back around
till episode 10 because the crossover is
meant to be sort of a self-contained
episode we're gonna get that Avengers 4
trailer real soon and we're supposed to
get a spider-man far from home trailer
on Saturday so I'll do videos for all
that stuff when it drops
congratulations not a wizard you're the
giveaway winner from my last big flash
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here for my flash 100th
episode video and click here for that
brand new Captain Marvel trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]